One Way We rise on our show is through
connection so we thought we'd do a new
segment where we share our takes on the
most controversial topics from past
episodes to see if we come to a
consensus on any this
is okay
run all right Jesse with the Run okay so
all we do is hit this button and our
super computer because it's totally
linked up to a computer we'll look back
through five seasons of shows to find
our most controversial subjects um or
topics rather then we're going to try to
settle things um on each top we're going
to we're going to settle right here are
you ready okay I'm ready to settle all
right boom well don't be ready to settle
that's not a way to
live oh can okay okay this is this one
came up from John Cryer when I was
talking to him and can you be friends
with an ex yes I could definitely be
friends with an ex I mean like how long
was the
relationship um I mean I've been friends
with a lot of exes that I've had and
they've been long relationships cuz most
of them in pretty good I mean we we we
go through stuff at the beginning of the
breakup but then once we come to our
grounds it's like we both we we we good
people we cool people are you friends
with any of your exes
no I mean here's the thing ain't no
judgment no Jud I'm not I'm not not
friends but I feel cuz the I'm cool with
i i only have a couple that I'm just
like hard pass but but no but you know a
couple of them though I don't have many
exes but like a couple of are cool
people there nothing wrong with them
there's If We R into each other we'd be
totally
friendly inv if they invited you to a
party with like like they said man we
having a party for some of family MERS I
yeah depending on the ex yeah no I would
be like okay cool yeah I'll show up like
I can I just feel like it can get
awkward for it depends on
who or who it is and it it's situational
yeah yeah but for mostly no no I feel
like that's awkward no Common Ground
[Music]
[Applause]
there thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home